hello and welcome sorry to this video
against
bear 856. unfortunately
two games i did not uh i couldn't put
into
youtube there because my
hard drive or yeah it's a solid state
drive but
the hard drive actually ran out of disk
space in the middle of recording
and unfortunately even two games
were lost this way i played two games
against
grand master oleg sayenko you might know
him he played in the
in the banter blitz cup and he really
did a great job there i thought
explaining his thought process i had two
games
it was funny i had one game that i won
because he accidentally resigned
instead of offering a draw that happened
to me as well
in in games and then
i i gave i mean he immediately um
offered a rematch and i took that um
considering that it was a bit awful yeah
i just got gifted a point
and and then in the middle of the second
game which i lost
the disk space ran out
i was a bit unfortunate yeah it's um
i did quite a number of
recordings for chessable recently and
those were still on my hard drive i
i usually transfer them quite quickly to
my
to my uh nar system the network
storage but i forgot about that didn't
do that
and then my disk space ran out when i
ordered that notebook
three years ago i didn't go for a huge
system drive ssds really have become
so much cheaper recently in recent
three years that you can easily go for
like two terabytes or something now for
the operating system drive and
at the time that wasn't so
easily done so i went for
i just have 265 gigabytes
which seems weird
by modern standards but at the time it
was kind of normal
okay now in this game here
i'm not better black seems fine here
f5 i did not expect
not saying it's bad i just didn't expect
it
okay maybe queen a4 my idea is
to just simply sacrifice on b7
and would i think be quite interesting
i get a pawn i get a protected past
c pawn it's not reacting to it at all
okay
yeah this g4 is dangerous i mean that's
absolutely certain
there is one issue if i take on b7 take
on c6
the rook is not hanging because bishop
h2
check i'm not winning a tempo here
and g4 is happening really quickly
if he plays g4 takes takes queen h4
e6 however is hanging check
[Music]
i got a million checks myself there
i shouldn't pre-move you never know what
they do
so g4 h takes f takes bishop takes
queen h4 i mean e6 is hanging
okay this is not that is not a strictly
necessary
move what he played
as the rook was not hanging the question
is what am i doing now
do i really i could play g4 in this
position
just stopping this
yeah i know running running out of time
a little bit
it's increment chess so
[Music]
no no time yet to be super hectic about
it
if he takes it bishop takes
i'm immediately threatening e6
and looks dangerous he has queen c7
interesting didn't expect that to happen
i don't even know what the what the idea
is actually
okay i'm taking this pawn
angling also for c6
queen c7 maybe
no
i wonder if i'm missing something
fundamental okay
[Music]
this is a real threat yeah f2 is
hanging at the end
i could play queen d6 in this position
it's not
totally terrible okay
i'm not happy with this but at least i'm
not getting checkmated
after the queen trade
oh ah
that was not very difficult to spot
completely overlooked that f2 is hanging
there what a shame
what a shame
i was a bad game
it was bad i mean i don't know what what
happened after them
after the um
the exchange sacrifice i don't think
this is so bad actually
so i'm mostly interested in looking at
this
so we got got this position
and um i know maybe it was just good for
me i mean
i don't really believe in stuff like f5
and g5
so take here okay the engine does not
really like it but
so rook a1 wow
intending to take okay so that rook
a7 that's not the a pawn is not hanging
okay that's not a very human move
but g4 is it seems to be is just rubbish
so
i mean a move that i did consider
actually rook a1 i did not consider but
this one i actually did consider
because that's a good prophylactic move
against any g4 business
yeah f2 is covered that's pretty nice
and the engine
assesses this is equal which is kind of
believable i think that
i i cannot be worse here that would be
very strange
with the c pawn and legs somewhat odd
placement here but
probably equal it's fair so this is a
bad move
because of queen to f7
yeah queen f7 bishop e1 that much i
saw and then just like rookie 7 is good
for black
because h5 black has black attacks okay
yeah g4 is just to weakening then
king g7 however is probably not great
so i should take and play bishop g4 as i
originally intended to do
okay so this this is not good then
yeah yeah if i cannot play queen d6 and
obviously i cannot
then i don't have a good move here so g4
was just a bad decision
i was just too
in a way to panic here there was really
not much to panic about
i also like g3 in this position as the
engine suggests
that gives me more stability this is for
example i think
bad ef and g4 exactly
so this looks good for white
and then it's equal yeah which is
believable i mean this
is i don't think it can be worse that
would be strange but
probably it's not going to be an
advantage either
i wonder like here
yeah the engine just says i should just
continue
and don't sacrifice and gives me a
pretty
large advantage yeah
you know this is a good move it's not
the now it's the
first choice this is a strong move
actually here queen to d1
it's really not easy to make because i
played this one
but it's still i mean i wanted to take
so this is yeah kind of
this narrative is clear i wanted to take
on b7 that's why i play queen a4 but
this is actually pretty good considering
that he has played g5
and weakened here all the light square
so i'm just now on that so
yeah this is just now not an idea at all
because my queen is there to help to
defend and in this case
like g4 is suicidal a queen would even
attack
so this is a in some way um a typical
computer move yes that is
kind of once you see it it's suggested
to you
i immediately see that it's good it's a
good option
but as a human it's almost impossible to
make at least like in blitz chess i
think in a tournament game also
i could probably find queen bee one
queen d1
as a good option you kind of
basically take your move back the the
move before
that you made but it's it's strong
because it acknowledges that the
situation on the queen side
has not changed it's favorable anyway
and on the king side
g5 has weakened black considerably and
i mean white has a clear idea just
double on the b4
file and say that b7 is weak so
yeah this is much better yeah i just
was too much um
invested in this idea of giving up the
exchange
and also what i pretty much
underestimated
is that how strong
black's potential attack still is i mean
something like g3 is probably stopping
it
from being like devastating but it's
still not easy to do
yeah to defend i thought that i would be
more um
let's say the annoyance factor of the
queen
would be so high that he cannot really
drum up anything here but
just one or two bad decisions and it was
dangerous
very dangerous and g4 was just a bad
move okay guys
thanks for watching